um ihrem ganz vorarlberg wird finden
wenn als folge hätte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nein also ich finde dieses verhalten als
voller erfolg
aber ich meine dass ich aus der
perspektive 2007 200 spitzel u schwimmt
man aufarbeiten so aber auf der
habenseite und jetzt sage ich finde dass
mir überhaupt
vorstellen
müsse dass leif brandt und der hotels
meine entschuldigung wer sie mir oder
also ich finde
tätig für mich erinnerte der punkt oder
muss ich mich als kind muss ich mir die
frage stellen was völlig gesperrt oder
darüber dass denken muss ich muss mich
fragen ist wichtig für mich stimmt das
für mich ist es richtig und kann nicht
frauen damit leben dass ich einfach
irgendwie fühlt und ihn zurücklassen der
frau wohl irgendwie am existenzminimum
muss leider kann ich mit dem umgeht das
ist finde ich frage mich wo man muss
beantwortet und beim erhalt des
tropischen zeit ja ich bin für mich
wichtig menschen immer lieber ich mache
alles was für mich stehen die anderen
sind mir egal der moment ist knallhart
zu suchen generell finde ich mich weder
pitts viel wert darauf dass man als
andere ich unter der über österreich
also ich finde andere im nächsten umfeld
okay aber im sinn vor was hinterlasse
ich meine nachwelt also dts vernichten
cfs mir total egal aus der sport mode
über mich denken ich möchte weniger egal
was die er über mich denken im hoch
kritisch
[Musik]